- [Host] This story begins in California.
To be more specific, here,
in an unspecified studio lot.
This is the story of a
TV producer, a physicist,
and the man who brought
them both together.
(calm orchestral music)
That's Wendy.
- I'm one of the co-producers
of Marvel's Agent Carter.
- [Host] In 2015, ABC
released the show Agent Carter
about a secret agent
working in the late 1940s.
In season two, they debuted a
character named Jason Wilkes.
- Jason is a scientist who
works at Isodyne Energy.
- [Host] And a science
character needs to sound
like a real scientist, kind of like this.
- Peggy enters to find Howard
at the chalkboard with Wilkes.
- Lambda is given...
- Lambda is given
by Planck's Constant divided by MC --
- [Howard] Except we can't calculate M
without an accurate reading of your mass.
No mass, no wavelength.
- [Host] So you need to
write science-y dialogue,
write science-y stuff on the chalkboard,
and have a science-y looking lab,
but you don't have any
science writers on staff?
- No, unfortunately we do not.
- [Host] So, what did you do?
- We called our friends up at the
National Academy of Sciences.
(phone ringing)
- Idea Exchange, it's Rick.
- [Narrator] This is Rick.
- Hey hey. I'm Rick.
I work at the National
Academy of Sciences.
We connect scientists and engineers
with people in Hollywood.
- [Host] People like Wendy?
- Yeah, we connected her with Clifford.
- Hi.
My name's Clifford Johnson.
I'm a professor in the Physics
and Astronomy Department
at USC.
- [Host] So it goes like this,
Rick pairs Clifford
with Wendy.
And they work together
to bring real science
into TV shows.
- Yeah.
For example, I got an
email one time saying,
"So how do you build an atomic bomb?"
And I had to sort of help them with that.
It was a lot of fun.
- [Host] Rick's team has
a database with a lot
of scientists in it.
Over 2,000.
And they've worked on some
major blockbuster films.
- [Rick] Iron Man Two and Three.
The Avengers: Age of Ultron.
Batman versus Superman.
Star Trek Into Darkness.
Mission Impossible Five.
Films and narrative have
been inspiring people
since the 19th Century
to go out and do great things
and build great things.
We're not trying to the
be the accuracy police,
we're not fact checkers per say.
What our goal is, is to inspire
more scientist characters
and better science in
mainstream media projects.
- [Host] And that's the
story about the hotline
for Scientists in Hollywood.
(phone ringing)
- Idea Exchange, it's Rick.
(upbeat music)